[Music]
welcome to
session 51 of the worlds of speculative
fiction series the book that we're going
to be talking about
in this particular session is
our scott backers the warrior prophet as
you can tell it's quite eight home
coming in at over 600 pages
uh including you know the the appendices
that have maps and
a few other things as well so this is
this is a real
tome here and it's part of a trilogy the
prince of nothing
trilogy which is part of the second
apocalypse series of seven books
the prince of nothing trilogy is the
first part then the
next four books comprise the the second
part
backer is supposed to be working on
a third part to it but nobody's quite
sure whether that's going to
come off or not the prince of nothing
series can be
read on its own as it has been by many
people
as self-contained as a really amazing
work
of epic fantasy
incorporating a lot of insights from
backers own
background in philosophy a lot of people
don't know that he
actually almost finished a phd
in philosophy he also studied literature
and he's so he's got an academic
background but he also
has a lot of interesting things to say
about the literary world and why
he chose fantasy you know why he got
into that and why we should be paying
close attention
to to the fantasy work that that's out
there
so we're going to talk a bit about
biography much
less than we did in the previous session
devoted to the first book the darkness
that goes before
we already covered a lot of the
biography so i don't think we need to do
that again
we're going to talk a good bit about
world building and what's
revealed about arwa the the
narrative universe that this is set
within
and we're going to talk a lot about some
of the key philosophical themes
about some of the character development
that's going on despite some of the
reviewers saying
that no character development took place
we're gonna and actually i should
mention
we're going to get into some discussion
about reviews before we do that though i
want to say so this is part of a
a longer series worlds of speculative
fiction that has been going on
since 2016 when we first moved back here
to
milwaukee and i partnered with the
brookfield public library to do a
one-year sequence on
worlds of speculative fiction allowing
me to do some guilty pleasure
reading of classic you know sci-fi
fantasy horror uh authors that that i
was particularly interested in looking
at the philosophical themes and the
narrative
universes that these authors
put out in in their works and it
continued on we're now
in the sixth year obviously kovid has
forced us to
change the format a bit what we do is a
video like this usually me talking for
about 90 minutes
about the work exploring some of the key
ideas it premieres
on youtube live people can interact with
me directly
as they're watching the video and then
it's followed by
a non-recorded more intimate zoom
session where we talk about the book the
themes the
key developments and all sorts of other
things
as well we're hoping eventually to get
back to
meeting in libraries and recording those
sessions like we did with earlier ones
but you know we'll see what happens so
this is what we're doing
for the time being if you're interested
in
other authors you know series
texts that that we've covered you want
to click the
show more and go into the video
description and there's a link to the
entire
series this is number 51 so you can
guess that we've actually covered
a lot of authors some of them several
times
in this series so um that said
i i want to begin by bringing up
something that
backer himself has one of his characters
muse about in the
the works and he says a book was never
read in in quotes
here is elsewhere language betrayed the
true nature of the activity
to say that a book was read was to make
the same mistake as the gambler who
crowed about winning
as though he'd take it by force to toss
the number sticks was to seize a moment
of helplessness nothing more
but to open a book was by far the more
profound gamble to open a book was not
only to seize a moment of helplessness
not only to relinquish a jealous
handful of heartbeats to the
unpredictable mark of another man's
quill
it was a lot to allow oneself to be
written for what was a book
if not a long consecutive surrender to
the movements of another soul
isn't that an interesting way to put the
act of reading and it might make you
think about
what's going on as we read this book it
also hearkens back to
insights about reading coming from for
example saint
augustine who talks about us you know
thinking that we're reading the book
when in reality the book is reading us
we often take books as if they're just
you know presentations of data
or information when really they are
something like the soul of another
encapsulated
in words giving us a perspective on
something
allowing us to enter into their world to
some degree
uh putting things forward that might you
know we might
have resistance against at first i don't
believe that you know and then
slowly seducing us bringing us into
their
perspective there are there are other
books where we might you know
read them great example of this is you
know he begins with a quote
in this book from uh emanuel
kant right he says this is from the
foundation the metaphysics of morals a
book
that i've taught many times here we see
philosophy brought to what is in fact a
precarious position
which should be made fast even though it
is supported by nothing in either heaven
and earth
here philosophy must show its purity as
the absolute sustainer of its laws and
not as a herald of laws which implanted
sensor who knows what tutelary nature
whispers to it and we can talk about why
why quote kant's groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals and why talk about
philosophy in a book of of literature
which doesn't have any philosophers
alive in it at the time there are
references
to philosophers and part of the answer
would be
what kant is actually after in that you
know
the book itself seems to be just about
morality but it's really about freedom
and the capacity to give oneself
laws structure orientation which a lot
of people think they're doing
in this text and in the the entire
series but
actually aren't they are you know just
their thoughts and
feelings are coming out of the darkness
that goes before right
so you know that's that's kind of an
interesting
uh thing to start with i also wanted to
bring up another
thing that that backer said in a reddit
ama
and i think this is more something to be
suggestive rather than to try
to explain right now but i'll read it to
you
he says if god is dead then fantasy is
his grave
i've spent 35 years now searching for
the secret of meaning
chasing research across disciplines and
arguments
through millennia what is it why does it
seem to be slowly boiling away
my short fiction and non-fiction on the
subject have been published in nature
midwest studies and philosophy in the
journal of consciousness studies
but epic fantasy has always been my
primary
vehicle notice i'm going to break my
rule there notice what he says there
vehicle not just like oh it's my passion
oh i'm just trying to tell a good story
it is a vehicle he says
for me fantasy fiction is the crash site
of meaning
create a world possessing the structure
of biblical israel or vedic india or
homeric greek
and it will be called fantastic create
an alternate intrinsically meaningful
world and the world will instantly
recognize
that it's especially false the very
shape of meaning now indicates delusion
and this i think should give us pause so
i guess you could say that for me
fantasy is a pretty serious thing
something worth pissing people off about
my nutty ambition was to write the only
kind of bible a human could write in
this remarkable and blasphemous age
a far different book of revelation more
honest to the complicated edges of the
world
equally horrific a textual crypt for the
corpse of
god and so a lot of rich
ideas there in in that quotation
i would say and so you know well worth
mulling over let's jump now
into looking at some of the things that
backer
said about the writing of this
particular work and i think that we can
draw them
in large part from this great interview
with uh
backer in ss sff
world you know the website by dag r
carried out by rob bedford
before that i want to read a little bit
from the forward that gets gets brought
up a lot or the acknowledgements rather
he says
since i had over 15 years to write the
darkness that comes before i really had
no idea what i was getting into when i
committed to finishing the warrior
profit within one year
i thought a year was a long time but now
after watching the seasons flicker past
my window quicker than commercials
i know better as a consequence of my
miscalculation i
inadvertently complicated the lives of
all those around me both professionally
and
personally never have i been indebted to
so many
i would like to thank and then he goes
down this entire list of people who he
has to thank
as a result and i think there's i mean
as an academic
myself and somebody who does a lot of
things a year
can go by incredibly fast and so i think
that's that's you know quite an
interesting insight now in this
interview
he's asked you know with darkness you
didn't have a deadline and most pressure
was probably from yourself as your own
editor
in completing the warrior prophet was
there a deadline
and or external pressure to complete the
work did the critical success
of darkness have an impact to your
approach in writing the warrior prophet
and so he goes on and he says i can
honestly say
that the last year was the most trying
year of my life
labor wise why i taught part-time
at fanshawe college here in london
london ontario
rewrote and defended the prospectus to
my dissertation and completed the
warrior prophet
i woke up at five a.m every morning
seven days a week between
may 2003 to march 2004
i took only one day off to get messy
with my buddies and watch the return of
the king you know
which came out at the time i wrote on
christmas i even worked with a hangover
on new year's day
and so you know you could say well that
doesn't sound too bad i mean you know
you're
by yourself you get to work in the
morning doesn't that sound wonderful
and i can tell you you know somebody who
actually did write a prospectus defended
the prospectus wrote a dissertation
there is an incredible amount of work
involved in that he was a graduate
student still at vanderbilt
while he's doing all of that and doing
it from a distance
teaching part-time very often
especially at the very beginning of your
teaching career
sounds like a nice you know little
excursion into things it's a lot of work
and he's also trying to write
this whole book at the same time so
you know that's that's actually quite a
monumental achievement
so he goes on in the interview and says
because i had about 15 years to finish
the darkness that comes before i really
had no idea
what i was getting into when i signed
the deals for the warrior prophet
and the thousand-fold thought suddenly
and here's a really interesting point of
view and this
actually i think kind of fit fits into
themes that that show up in these books
my private passion had become a
collective enterprise
and i don't just mean the immediate
circle of commercial interests that
suddenly spring up around an author
people like your agent editor publicist
greedy relatives and so on
there's your readers as well buying into
an uncompleted series especially by an
unknown author is an act of faith
26 dollars is a tank of gas or a week's
worth of groceries for me
the idea of defaulting on my end of the
bargain tormented me
and the idea of writing anything other
than the book i felt a compelled to
write was unthinkable pressure
pressure so he wanted this book to
measure
up to what the previous book had
had provided to readers and he says add
to this all the crazy reviews the
darkness that comes before was racking
up
i really thought the book was a love it
or hate it work which was no problem as
far as i was concerned
because i didn't write it for everybody
i thought the reviews would be split and
that the raves if i received any would
be peppered with
telling criticisms after all the reviews
the book is received i think the first
review i
read comes closest to my own feelings
towards the book
everyone else has been too kind
including you rob
this is where i think the pressure was a
good thing because my schedule was so
tight
i really had no time to fret that much
over whether the warrior profit would
live up to its predecessor
as the collective concerns faded into a
single imperative
right write write your ass off and as
strange as it may sound suddenly there
was me the world the characters in a
blank screen
just like the good old days and then he
says now that i have time i'm freaking
out
so you know this is this is a product of
you know grinding away getting things
done
working with the characters the world
that he already had in place
but now getting it down on on paper
i do want to bring up one other thing
he's asked was the warrior prophet a
more difficult work
and backer says both books were
difficult for different reasons
and you know talking about warrior
prophet he says i already had the world
in place
and in certain aspects this made things
so much easier
even still i found the new difficulties
that arose just as challenging
and so a little bit later he says the
main difficulties i
faced in the warrior prophet stemmed
directly from the outrageous goals i'd
set myself
right so he set himself up for this in a
sense
the world the book is about conquest
the myriad and often bizarre ways in
which humans submit to one another
whether through violence or seduction so
on the one hand there's the conquest of
the heathen by the holy war i really
wanted the holy war to come across
as a living breathing thing as an
alternate protagonist in fact
doing this however required a line of
quasi-historical narration
threaded through the various strands of
character narration
since i wanted to play these two lines
against each other in interesting ways
they became painstaking affairs so
that's that's tough to do right
also i find the tendency is to gloss
over the details when telling the story
of collective actions
to narrate at a level that invites
abstractions that's what makes history
boring to many
people so there is this continuous
struggle to keep the holy war
concrete to keep it alive in my reader's
imagination
if i think i succeeded it's only because
i recognize it's impossible to carry
everyone with you and then he says on
the other hand there's the conquest of
the holy war
from within by calhouse here my goal was
to tell a story that
shows a prophet coming to power rather
than simply telling it
think about the difference between
describing a conversation that
captivates a listener and actually
giving
that conversation the former need not be
captivating at all
whereas the latter has to be somewhat if
the reader is to find its consequences
plausible so that is some tough stuff
to write now if you think about it you
know he's
he's placing himself in a
long-standing literary context
in which people have managed to pull
these sorts of things off this
grand epic historical semi-historical
really fantasy narrative that doesn't
get dry
or abstract because the characters
themselves are absolutely central to it
without turning the characters into like
you know it's just a battle of
superheroes against super villains or
anything like that
on the one hand and then to tell the
story of how
something is subverted from within
progressively by the warrior prophet how
to tell a story that shows somebody
who we as readers and not all readers
responded to this but we as readers
could say yeah i would i would like buy
into this guy
in this you know and if you think about
who else has managed to pull that off
in the sci-fi fantasy world obviously uh
frank herbert with dune right
uh and and thinking about um
you know uh the the development of of
the the the whole uh you could call it
emperor sequence and sub subplantation
of the old empire by paul atreides the
mod dib right
and i think we could come up with a lot
of other examples as
as well but that's difficult stuff to to
narrate so i think that
is uh some important insights about the
development of this book in lieu of
biography what we're talking about more
is
you know we might call it the biography
of a book and it's
author carried along i want to talk
about
some of the reviews next because i think
that they can be
quite revealing after having
re-read and really thoroughly re-enjoyed
and saw so much more
in this book than i did the first time
around when i was kind of you know get
getting through it to try to
find out what was going to happen next
knowing the story ahead of time
i thought it would be good to see what
other people had to say
about the work more or less from its own
time
since i first read this only you know
a year and a half to two years ago and
then you know re-read it recently
there's there's not that sense of okay
this is the new thing that's coming out
i wanted to see what people
had to say and there were you know uh
quite a few positive reviews
a lot of negative reviews out there on
the
internet you know the blogosphere about
it and we'll talk about what people
found
negative in the work and some of the
responses that we might have to that
but first let's talk about some of the
positive things so
victoria strauss who has been a quite
important reviewer and engager of backer
writes all that careful preparation pays
off in the warrior prophet the
preparation that was carried out in the
first book the darkness that came before
in which because the world and its
inhabitants have already been so
thoroughly established very little
digression is needed
at 600 pages one couldn't exactly call
this a lean
novel but it is a well-knit and muscular
one with more straightforward plot line
than its predecessor and a headlong
narrative momentum
that keeps the reader riveted to the
page in some way it's less character
centered than the first volume
for where darkness focused most
intensely on the many viewpoint
characters whose struggles and choices
often eclipse
the larger drama stirring around them in
the warrior prophet the larger drama
dominates
particularly the progress of the holy
war though it could be said that the
holy war is itself a character complete
with its own viewpoint
an omniscient god's eye perspective that
encompasses the entire field
of battle now i i think she's actually
wrong about
that because if that was the case we
would also have the perspective
of the phoneme you know much more
represented instead it's really the
initery
and what's happening with them and we do
get some perspectives much more
than others in in this again she she
goes on and says underpinning everything
is the meticulous world building
ar was a creation of enormous depth
unique in detail fascinating and custom
in history
no aspect has been neglected it is for
instance one of the few fantasy settings
i've encountered in which there appears
to be a real literature this is a very
interesting insight on her part i think
literature for literature's sake that is
not mere window dressing
or a way for the author to sneak in a
few info dumps
via an ancient document or two creating
a world is not so difficult
anyone with a little invention and time
a lot of time can do it
but to create a world so nuanced so
consistent so fraught with the kind of
moral ambiguity we
daily encounter in our own non-fantasy
lives is
far more difficult and again i i would
say
in broad respects i think she's she's
right you know one of the few fantasy
settings in which there appears to be a
real literature
um yeah i mean
if we include new weird i would say we
probably do have
a literature within that right
or or even old weird tales or horror
um fantasy that's a very broad thing but
i mean she's i don't know if she's right
about the exclusivity
she is definitely right about having
created a world
that already has long-standing
uh disputes modes of thought that aren't
just
political or like you know epic in the
sense of good versus evil
but really um quite quite
deep uh in that respect
so i think those are some good insights
um
[Music]
james schallenberg in another
review says i'm pleased backers kept
some of the brutally unheroic aspects of
his historical model for the series
the real-life crusades some of the
typical fantasy notions get in the way
of this
notably combined search for the ultimate
evil the consult and all the related
prophecies on the other hand this makes
akamian
one of the few sympathetic characters in
the book is everyone else is
soaked in blood for no reason other than
personal aggrandizement however thinly
cloaked by religious rhetoric i i'd say
that
schullenberg's actually wrong about that
we'll get to that in a moment
but he says uh the warrior prophet is an
exceptionally violent book and
rightfully so for its subject matter
about the only historically based
atrocity not included so far would be
the sack of a friendly city
for example the attack on byzantium but
these are definitely vicious
killers he goes on and he says
also worth noting is the way that backer
keeps his magic strictly in the
background
in terms of narrative strategy backer
accomplishes this by making
practitioners
rare the various sorceress schools have
few adherents and military commanders
tend not to tell their soldiers the fact
that it's worth sacrificing thousands of
them even to kill
one sorcerer in interestingly the
band-aid often ignored her mocked have
some of the most powerful magic and
there's a blowout of a scene later in
the book where we
finally see akamian defending himself so
some good insights there i think some
good points of view
um i would disagree that
acamian is one of the few sympathetic
characters in the book i
i would say that even kanir
is is a sympathetic character in many
respects at least
for me and that um interestingly
um backer himself in another interview
so that conifas
is one of the characters that he
actually quite quite likes
um many of us i think find him
detestable but
you know so you know i think he's wrong
about that
i also think that the you know the
ultimate evil the consult doesn't
actually
make the book lesser in any any way but
so there we get some you know fairly
positive
uh characterizations of this book you
know contemporary to
it's coming out there were a lot of
complaints about the book
in the um online literature that i could
see
and what did the complaints really
center around well the violence was an
integral part of it why do the battle
scenes have to be so bloody
you know there were some who deplored
that
um there was there were a lot of
accusations that
in this book the warrior prophet there
is a
serious lack of character development
and we'll talk about that i think that's
definitely worth taking
up um there's also you know complaints
about there being too much marching
too much holy war and you know it's sort
of like saying
i'm gonna read a romance novel there's
too much kissing in it
you know uh and and why do they have to
be so much focused on
romantic attachment why couldn't they
have talked more about grain prices in
britain in 1838
so some of these are kind of kind of
silly complaints
one that's really quite interesting that
we're going to get into
the idealization of kel huss you know
the whole book
centers around and i think this is
people getting seduced by the title
the whole book centers around the
warrior prophet and his story he's the
only real character
this is a glorification of of somebody i
mean some went so far as to suggest that
backer was
basically engaging in wish fulfillment
about his own
you know desires to control things and
subvert from within
um but like i said we'll get to that in
a moment another
key issue that came up was
well there are two issues when it comes
to sexuality
one is that there are too few female
characters
and that they are all depicted
as essentially [ __ ] or prostitutes
who may in fact have power like the
empress does but does so through
the use of her sexuality so that this is
you know an inherently
typically misogynistic and you know tone
deaf to women's concerns kind of uh
story um and you know
we'll get into that in a moment the
other one that i saw on a few websites
was
the sexuality there's too much
discussion of
of sex scenes and a lot of it's just
gross
you know uh they complain about
necrophilia they complained about the
skin spies they complained about you
know all of the
sexuality that's involved with the
consult in general you know
black semen isn't that terrible you know
and a lot of this i think came from
people who are just kind of prudish
basically
but there is something to that so so
let's let's look at some things
again in another interview um carried
out by dag r
with r scott backer in sff world
he says this is the question put to
backer
the genre exhibits a strong albeit
recent tradition for subverting gender
stereotypes by presenting worlds in
which strong independent female
characters are plausible or even
expected
yet your world is as patriarchal as the
reality that inspired it i expect that
this theme
makes up for a good bit of the
discussions you have about your creation
possibly detracting from what you
actually want to talk about
is it difficult to resist the temptation
to put something like a
badass tomboy warrior princess with
snappy dialogue and a heart of gold
into the books so here's what backer
says in response to that
first let me say i think i should be
called out onto the carpet for this
on this issue simply because i cover
some pretty troubling ground
i certainly don't believe in quota
characterization either to be
politically correct
or to broaden the gender appeal of my
books leave this for the after school
specials
i also don't think that depiction
automatically equals endorsement
the question people should be asking it
seems to me is whether i
reinforce negative gender stereotypes
or problematize them if the books
provide enough risk to argue this
question
then the answer to me it seems to me
automatically becomes the latter that
they're
actually problematizing rather than just
merely reinforcing
then he says but the fact remains a lot
of people get hung up on my female
characters on the one hand i
self-consciously chose the harlot
the waif and the herodine for my female
characters
yet some seem to think a kind of
unconscious moral defect chose them for
me if so it would be a truly
colossal coincidence that i would happen
to pick the three misogynistic types i
mean isn't it
obvious that i'm up to something
critical on the other hand i wanted my
fantasy world to be realistic to temper
our yearning for pre-modern times
with a good look at how ugly things got
particularly in times of war
when bad things happen to my female
characters it's the circumstances that
are being criticized
not the characters themselves that's
that's an interesting
perspective as well i would say they
says but people get hunches while they
read and once they do confirmation bias
goes to work
and this is simply one among many
reasons why we always buy
our own [ __ ] and the text i think
possesses more than enough ambiguities
for people to spin any number of
self-validating interpretations it's
when they
insist their interpretation is the only
interpretation or even worse that it
captures what's really going on in my
being that i become baffled so
he's he's saying listen i'm not going
about you know trying to create a
fantasy world in which you know all of
these
great female heroines suddenly replace
all the male ones or you know are on a
position of equality
i'm gonna tell stories but it's the way
that i'm telling it that you need to pay
close attention to not just you know
what numbers i have
or you know what's going on and i would
argue as i'm going to a little bit later
that
estimate undergoes some pretty
significant
development in this even if the empress
and serway
perhaps don't and that you know the
um the skin spies you know despite the
fact that they don't have a soul
you know and and they're essentially a
different
gender all together um there's something
else
interesting going on with them
particularly in relation to
uh kanir and and can iyer himself is
is a very interesting character in this
respect you know super hyper masculine
in some ways and yet uh in other ways
um you know kind of subverting that
backer also in the reddit ama
said something about the i think this
applies essentially to the consult
he says i sexualize evil in my world
which morally
charges the stakes i think but i wanted
to do this
against an inhuman awe-inspiring
background
ultimately the point is to connect the
horror within the book to the horror
confronting all of us
now even though the vast majority remain
blissfully
unaware of it i think he's talking about
nihilism there and all the things that
come
come out of it or are you know
catastrophe
times in terms of meaning but you know
the the incroi
are as they call themselves a race of
lovers and sexuality
is something that is
at the heart of their way of approaching
things a very exploitative sexuality
in many respects one which is
tied together with violence and you know
is backer
um gross and horrible for
exploring that no because is he
endorsing it
i don't see that happening in fact he
seems to be
helping us to be aware about how
seductive that could be
within the inc roy within the
trunk within the skin spies
of the consult so
um a little bit later
uh i i do want to come back to this this
other issue of calhous
in a couple interviews he says some
really interesting things about
um calhous you know asanabor
the the you know central main character
among several main characters and
um in an interview with jessica strider
in sci-fi fan letter
she asked what was the hardest scene for
you to write and he said all the calhous
scenes and the prince of nothing were
exceedingly difficult
the scene at the end of the darkness
that comes before where he lays the
groundwork for his subsequent domination
of the holy war
that was a challenge as much because of
my inexperience as for its complexity i
think
in another interview with victoria
strauss he says
in a formal sense portraying calhouse's
superhuman intelligence was relatively
easy
i would start with straight dialogue for
calhouse's scenes
which i would go over again and again
each time giving calhouse more in way of
insights and observations
it was the substance of these insights
and observations that proved exceedingly
difficult to write
but here again i had the luxury of time
i would work and rework them until i
eventually came up with something
calhouse-worthy i took a shotgun
approach
but there were other challenges as well
he says
we humans tend to be a credulous of
everything
to say save our credulity something i
forgot while writing the first draft of
the warrior prophet
originally my idea was to slowly
externalize calhouse that's the term
that he's using
meaning to move away from his point of
view and show more and more his
manipulation from the outside
i'd have a wicked gleam in my eye as i
wrote thinking what a sneaky bastard
but my readers kept coming back to me
with things like i'm so relieved kelos
is coming around
it turned out that calhouse was duping
them as thoroughly as he was duping the
characters
they knew he wasn't trustworthy just as
we know commercials aren't trustworthy
and yet the instinct was to think ah
it's okay it's just so strong
and so he says that was perhaps my
second greatest difficulty i had
writing kelvis depicting him in such a
way that my readers would always have a
sense of the distance between his claims
and his intentions i'm still not happy
with the way i resolved this
problem so kel huss himself
is a seductive character
that has to be invested with this
capacity to seduce the reader
as well as the characters you know it
reminds me in a certain respect although
this is not a perfect
analogy to how when when
you know philip k dick uses the
oracle meaning the e jing as not just
something within
the man in the high castle but to help
him write the man in the high castle
and later in an interview says the
oracle you gotta watch it it's sneaky
it's deceptive you can't trust it
you know i came to realize this and
writing that kel huss
is similarly something like that
again in in another interview in uh ssf
world
sff world sorry he says it's a the
strange thing
is that to write is to be calhouse in a
sense in the same way calhouse can think
a dozen
thoughts and assess numerous
possibilities where others can only
think one i get to spend hours even days
cooking up stuff for a calhouse section
that only takes several minutes to read
i just keep thinking and thinking and
sooner or later i get lucky and come up
with something smart or badass sounding
to give calhouse
he's the one percent smart me 100 of the
time which is why i don't trust him for
a second
this is the author talking about his own
character who is you know so so central
to not just the series but particularly
this book finally
in in a great interview with victoria
strauss
we also you know get some discussion
about the
holy war itself and essentially about
the series and
and this book he says in narrative terms
i wanted the holy war to become a
character to be something that suffers
survives crises
and develops as a result in this sense i
look at those omniscient sections
um i you know a kind of collective
third-person centered
point of view i also wanted the holy war
to be entirely believable a collective
version of the psychological
realism i try to bring to my characters
both for consistency's sake
and because i think believability is a
necessary precondition of conjuring
or the tickle of it anyway there's a lot
going on in that passage
so let's just you know reiterate some of
these points
the holy war in this book becomes a
character a character that encompasses
other
characters as well um he
he thinks that it's important to use
psychological realism
both for consistency's sake and so that
the fantasy that he's writing
can do the job that he thinks fantasy is
supposed to do
a little bit later in that he says
um another thematic motive for the
historical voice has to do with the
question
that animates the darkness that comes
before and the warrior prophet from
start to fish
finish what does it mean to belong to
something
larger than oneself the statement
there's more than me
has got to be a signature human insight
the more
calls upon us in innumerable ways draws
us out of the narrow circle of our
self-interest and makes us human or so
we like to think now that's a great
observation
you know oh i belong to something bigger
than myself great but what if the bigger
than yourself chews you up and spits you
out
or what if it's uh gonna bring about an
apocalypse or what if it's just about
other people's self-interest
or what if and we can go on and on and
on what if it requires you to do
horrible atrocities
to other people to show your devotion
not always necessarily good so he goes
on and he says
what is this more is it a lover
a movement of faith history or people is
it a god
what happens to our relationships when
we embrace any one
or combination of these and what happens
when this more becomes a weapon
only the epic allows you to fully
explore these questions i think
i want to say only epic fantasy but that
sounds too flattering to be trusted so
that's one of the key
central themes that is being explored
here
while calhouse is subverting the holy
war
from within to his own purposes and
creating a new kind of nation
a new kind of belonging a new kind of
human unity that appears to be like all
love
fate destiny but is really cold
calculation
machination seduction subversion
a little bit later he says this is the
last part of this this interview that i
want to bring
up lastly i wanted to explore the
collective dimension of belief
and desire all our actions are
underwritten by our beliefs and our
desires we do action a rather than
action b
because we believe action a will give us
what we want what about extreme actions
or better yet
extreme collective actions what kinds of
beliefs and desires
underwrote for example the lunatic
extremes the unthinkable atrocities
committed the impossible obstacles
overcome
of the first crusade one of the reasons
i cleaved so closely to the actual
history of the first crusade was
i didn't think people would be able to
believe the events i attribute to the
holy war
otherwise and all this i think comes
back to transcendence
to the belief in more which for some
reason seems to breed both the best and
the worst
in humanity so you know what we've
really got here
is a an epic fantasy
of you know capital e
epic scope in terms not just of you know
great characters
uh you know wonderful storytelling cool
world building but philosophical depth
philosophical depth particularly in
terms of epistemology
and in terms of moral philosophy
where the metaphysics which includes
magic is kind of serving that
along the way so this has been a long
disquisition or digression let's talk
now about
what more world building happens in this
story as some of the reviewers who we
just talked about
earlier noted there's less world
building going
on within the warrior prophet compared
to
the earlier volume the darkness that
comes before
and it makes good sense in part because
they've already staged a lot
of the places and their connections with
each other
there is a considerable amount of you
could call it
continuing world revelation rather than
world building going on in the
discussions of the cities and the
deserts and the locations and
the in interrelations between different
places
as the holy war progresses southward and
actually we
also learn you know a little bit here
and there about
some of the nations of the three seas
that form
part of the holy war as a matter of fact
we get to learn a good bit more about
some
than others and a lot of this comes
through
exposition in terms of the
characters talking with each other and
revealing things to
each other and you can say that nearly
all of the action with the exception of
a few
let's call them vignettes that are
happening elsewhere almost all of it is
taking place
as the holy war is moving south so it's
happening
in the wake of that and and you know if
you've got the book i think you want to
look at that last
map the western three c's that shows you
you know the progression and that can be
quite
helpful i will say this that there is
one little vignette towards the the very
end that takes place in the high north
or what's left of it
uh with these these people who are
taken by they're called they call
themselves the uh
waregda and they're searching for their
their stolen
wives and children who have been taken
by the sronk
and by the the consult essentially
who are using them to try to find out
where the
um the sort of you know now revealed
enemy to them are and actually we have a
final
uh thing there's one key question
that is being asked who are the dunyan
right who who are these people that are
living within the
shadow of holy golgotharth to quote one
of the
uh old names that we're going to talk
about before
but other than that um you know and and
some things happening at the periphery
of the holy war
and where uh akamian is is taken by the
scarlet spires and then has to get his
way back
along with cinemas who tries to rescue
him and who is tortured and blinded
it's all happening in the wake of this
so i think that
you know we can talk about some of the
key features
one that i found particularly
interesting is the
battle plane where they're going to
fight again
the in rithi forces fighting against
the kianes and and their various
tributaries
and this is a site of an ancient
battle where the no god himself or
itself whatever the no god happens to be
was finally killed after the
the high north was basically devastated
and and uh destroyed and you know
exploited by
the consult and the battle plane is
described in some really bizarre ways
you know everybody has bad dreams the
dreams for akamian are even worse than
than usual and more vivid than usual the
dead
as they say they don't escape the battle
plan
of the battle plane rather and there's
bones and skulls and all sorts of stuff
that comes up through the very
ground so that's kind of an interesting
feature and everything else is presented
in a fairly
linear way but that's that's a key place
for
you could say producing a kind of
conviction
that is going to lead to a greater
understanding
of who it is that they genuinely are
facing off against
um you know we learn a little bit more
about the high north
largely through revelations by
characters we're going to talk about
some of that in a bit but also through
the continuing sequence of akamian's
dreams
the holy war itself um
there's some very interesting
discussions about what's what's going on
and so we're going to shift a little bit
from
world building into talking about the
progression of this
as we call it character of the holy war
or you might
it's not really a character it's more
like a
a force a river a current that's that's
going along
and you know we can say that there's um
at first this this sort of assemblage of
the great names and that continues on
throughout all of it this council of the
great names which includes
you know the nobility some of whom are
just puppets
like the you know high ion um uh king
who's really just a puppet for the
scarlet spires
um we have the representative of the
noncer empire and confused we have
uh representation of the
with the shirelle knights and and the
the shiro representative
and then we have all of these nobility
some of whom are kind of
you know like salbon um they're nobles
but they're
they're yet to find their own place and
so we've got all of that going on and
then we have this these two
main people who are rivaling
each other over who is going to
effectively guide the the military force
and one of them is confoss right who had
been up for being the commander
and then the other is knight and um
kanir has been chosen to be
the war leader and there's some very
interesting things that kanye
says at a few places that i want to
point out about this so
in one point he's talking about
reading the the battle plane itself
here we go he's talking with
proyous and um
so he's he's canao connier says are you
assured of your victory and
and priya says assured but of course and
then he's he's talking with him
and prayer says because god has willed
it and
uh canair says what about scarous
couldn't he give the same
answer you know as the praying to the
solitary god
and then a little bit later on he says
um
this is canary he says
the memorialist recited verses dedicated
to each of the nancer
columns stories that describe their
devices their arms and their metal in
battle so that when the tribes went on
pilgrimage or at a war
they could read the nancer battle line
this is why the people lost at keoweth
confess switches columns devices told us
a false story
and project says any fool knows how to
read his opponent's line
kenair says then tell me what story do
you read on the battle plane
and uh priya says how am i supposed to
know i recognized only a handful
knighter says i recognized all of them
of the great kianin houses there are
many
only two thirds rode against us on the
plains of mangetta
of these several likely token
contingents depending on how many
enemies scouris entertains among his
peers
after the massacre of the vulgar holy
war
many among the heathen including the
pajira were no doubt contemptuous of the
holy wars
threat and so being able to like know
who
is from where which is sort of like
world building within the world right
that's very important for being able to
strategize in in war itself
a bit later there's this talk about
teaching right
and prayas is talking to the great names
and he says at mangetta
you learn the kia nina faster this this
means no matter where you assemble
scholars will assemble first
but at mengeta you also learn the
strength of your footmen and more
importantly you taught right
and so you know that that's quite an
interesting idea
as well there's this uh discussion where
um uh confis actually backs up
conor and then there's this long uh
discussion a little bit later not that
much later
in the book where kanye is talking about
war
as a way of convincing one's foe
so he says that
kenair says this is how you convince
your foe
and uh calhouse says convince and kenner
says this war
is simply your war made honest kelly
says belief you're
you're saying battle is a disputation of
belief an argument
and so kanye goes on he says the
memorialist now the second reference to
the memorialists right who are these
these are the people among
the skill vendi who keep their their
knowledge alive and then teach them
they call battle a great quarrel both
both hosts take the field believing they
are the victors
one host must be disabused of that
belief attacking his flank or his rear
overrawing him bewildering him shocking
him killing him
these are all arguments meant to
convince your foe he's defeated
he who believes he's defeated is
defeated and so
calhouse says so in battle conviction
makes true
and uh the schovendi says
as i said it is honest and a little bit
later on he says again about the
memorialists when the memorialist
council the chieftains before battle
they bid them to recall that in conflict
all men are bound to one another some by
chains some by rope some by strings
all of different lengths they call these
bindings the
maya to free the ligaments of war these
are all just ways of describing the
strength and flexibility of a
formations angotoma these kiane the
people would call
men of the long chain they can be thrown
apart but they will pull themselves
together
the galioth and tydoni we would call men
of the short chain
left alone such men would battle in
battle only disaster or attrition can
break the chains
of such men and then he goes on and he
says the leader
must continually appraise and reappraise
the string rope and chain of his enemy
and the men and this is a very
interesting point now isn't it again
having to do a bit with world building
we're getting to see something about the
characteristics of people
and this is typical backer right through
the eyes and the discourse of
one of the particular peoples the
skilvendi who are the ones who can tell
you the most in some respects
about war except for of course confused
right who can also
do so and so it's it's uh
i'm going to close on this just by
saying this provides us with an
instance and an example of how backer
is continuing his world building
in this particular novel
one of the key thematics that our scott
backer is
employing and is actually making very
central
to the entire prince of nothing trilogy
a little bit less so perhaps in
the books that follow is what we could
summarize as in in two ways
one is not knowing who the true enemy
is and therefore planning and acting
against and responding against enemies
that
are not genuine enemies but could
actually be your allies in other better
circumstances
and not understanding that there are
plots within plots within plots
and what i'm going to add to this that i
think is really central to
backers own uh thoughts and
preconceptions and
and uh preoccupations uh this comes out
in a lot of his other
like interviews and essays is that
people are often you might say
constrained driven channeled by the
assumptions
of their particular group along with
its history its traditions its its ways
of looking at things interpretation
is very important and so
misinterpretation happens
when you can't recognize some new
information coming in that should have
you say
wait a second things are not mapping on
to each other properly and instead you
kind of you know
force it into the hermeneutic
context that you already have and and
you make it fit and this is where
people make major mistakes and not just
people but people and
in this case factions as well
and so you know who is the ultimate
enemy in this entire thing well it's the
the unholy consult that has been
engaging
in in this attempt to essentially
you know reduce the number of souls
within this world
down to a certain level the consult is
a bringing together
of some human beings who are sort of the
at first the junior partners but it but
eventually become
a major part of it the ink roy these
creatures that
uh you know crash landed on this
world and you know encountered the
non-men
who themselves can become erratics
after the womb plague which we'll talk
about some some other time
and they join together in an attempt to
use the technology that they have to
essentially
dominate the entire world bring about
the no god
cause the death and suffering and rape
and exploitation
of so many beings and so that's you know
sort of the ultimate enemy
and um what's going on
with with everybody else well you know
akamian
and the mandate they they know or they
think
you know they suspect that the consult
might still be out there but akamian has
even got his doubts for a while until he
and you know sees the skin spy uh in the
previous
book and the you know the mandates
themselves
some of them believe some of them don't
they they are now sort of galvanized
into action
um when it comes to the others we can
talk about
the other um schools
of of sorcery and so the main ones that
would be important for this would be the
scarlet spires we see a lot of their
uh back and forth about this and then
the cesaro
who are you know associated with with
kion right and and the
um kyani's religion the phantom right
and so both of them are actually
misrecognizing
each other as being the
the enemy that is coming from the
uh consult um
the scarlet spires also think that the
mandate you know the bunch of old fools
they just happen to have this really
great gnosis it'd be great if we could
get it from them
there are also these other schools of
sorcery but they don't play that big of
a role
within this this particular branch of
the
the story and then we also have you know
the
you know enemy relationship between the
keanes and the phanim um and
the other main opposed religion
of indrathism which is being you know
practiced and at least
given fealty by many around the three
seas and you know this holy war is
declared by
mythonet in the previous book you know
it starts out with some
well is it going to be a war against the
sorcerers because they hate them
or is it going to be a war against the
phantom we don't know and and then and
then it does get uh declared by the
shira so um
the real you know story that's going on
here is there's a holy war that's
happening
and the holy war is being used to
further a lot of people's um
[Music]
beliefs choices um
values right the emperor wants to use it
to retake parts of the nancer empire and
become an
aspect emperor once again it's not going
to happen
you know some of the other people like
salbon want to
get some territory for themselves
the scarlet spires view this as an
opportunity for revenge
um you know it it gets subverted from
within by
calhouse who's going to use this holy
war for his own purposes
and so you know a lot of people are at
war with each other fighting each other
spilling blood
uh without really understanding
who th these things should be directed
against and so you know
the the discovery that the skin spies
have infiltrated
practically all of the great factions
this is a major
uh deal major significance
and you know calhouse is really one of
the main characters
and we find out that
at a certain point calhouse uh realizes
that everything has changed for him
uh here we go
uh he says everything had transformed
since he had taken drewcus akamian as
his teacher
the ground of this world he now knew had
concealed many many secrets from his
brethren and these are the dunyan
the logos remained true but its ways
were far more devious and far more
spectacular than the dunyan had ever
conceived and the absolute
the end of ends was more distant than
they'd ever imagined so many obstacles
so many forks in the past so even these
people who like
you know seem to like know everything
they're deluded as well
about the nature of things it goes on
and says despite his initial skepticism
calhouse had come to believe much of
what akamian had claimed over the course
of their discussions he believed the
stories of the first apocalypse
he believed the faceless thing before
him was an artifact of the consult but
the calimonian
prophecy the coming of the second
apocalypse such things were absurd by
definition the future couldn't
anticipate the present
what came after couldn't come before
could it
and then he goes on and he says there
was so much that must await his father
so many
questions right and calhouse is going to
figure out that well
you know not only is there sorcery not
only is there
all of this other stuff going on the
consult existing
maybe there is prophecy as well maybe
the past
and the future are related in ways
different than the dunyan
understood it through their essentially
you know philosophy of nature
and and psychology and so
you know this is this is quite an
interesting
issue he goes on he says a thousand
possibilities galloping across the
trackless step of what was to come
a hundred scenarios flashing through his
soul some branching and branching
terminally deflected from his objectives
others flaring out in disaster he's
trying to use the probability
trance to understand what he ought to do
a little bit earlier in the book
very early on actually in chapter two
there we go um
akamian is is talking to kel huss
and tells him about the prophecy
and calhous says you know after akamian
says you you're the sign he says that
doesn't make sense akka the fact that
i'm here means nothing
nothing now i'm here and before i was in
there we go and if my bloodline reaches
back as far as you say than an
ana on a serum has always been here
whatever that
may be and then uh
there's a revelation akka says i found
them i found the consult the night you
and the others celebrated price as
victory over the emperor i was summoned
to the
adam uh and mean heights by
no less than uh ikere kunfas and brought
to the imperial catacombs
and he goes on and he tells him about
this and he says listen he actually
called me
chigra which is sathwasa's name
in the perverted speech of the shrunk
somehow he could see sethwatha's trace
within me
for another he had no face he was an
abomination of the flesh
a spy that can mimic the form of any man
without sorcery or sorceries mark
perfect spies
and he goes on and said well what does
that mean it means the consult has
mastered the old science
shrunk bash rags dragons all the
abominations of the incarioi
are artifacts of the techne the old
science created long
long ago when the non-men still ruled
the arwa it was thought destroyed when
the inquiry were annihilated
before the tusk was even written but
these skin spies are
new new artifacts of the old science
and if the consult has rediscovered the
old science there's a chance they know
how to resurrect
mag farao the no god and so
you know this this places everything
into
context a context that we the readers
can understand
and a context that some of the
characters themselves
can understand um by the very end of the
the work after
calhouse has been denounced as a false
prophet
and uh akamian goes to prayas and the
other great names
and uh canar you know fights sarkelis
and and all of these things are sort of
revealed we now get to the point
where we can have a um
we can have everybody else in on the
great
secret and so this happens towards the
the very end of the book akamian tells
us
a bit of a story i'm not going to trace
all of this out
but he's he's talking to um
process and he says
thousands of years before men had
crossed the great carissus before even
the chronicle of the tusk was written
the non-men ruled these lands and like
us they ward amongst themselves
for honor riches yes even for faith but
the greatest of their wars they fought
not against themselves
nor even against our ancestors the
greatest of their wars they fought
against the incario a race of
monstrosities a race who exalted in the
subtleties of the flesh
forging perversities from life the way
we forge swords from iron iron
swank bashrog even raku dragons are
relics of their ancient wars
led by the great kujara kin moi these
non-men kings battled them across the
plains
through the high and deep places of the
earth after ordeal and grievous
sacrifice they beat the incarroy back to
their first and final stronghold
a place the non-men called min heroicus
the pit of obscenities
i'll not recount the horrors of that
place suffice it to say the incario were
overthrown extinguished or so it was
thought
and the non-men cast a glamour around it
so it would remain forever
hidden and then they retired to the
remnants of the ruined world
a triumphant yet broken race centuries
later the men
of iana descended the cairosus howling
multitudes of them led by their
chieftain kings are fathers of yore
you know their names for their
enumerated in the chronicles of the text
the tusk they swept the dwindling
non-men before them
sealing up their great mansions driving
them into the sea
for an age knowledge of the incari and
men
heroicus passed from all souls only the
non-men remembered and they dared not
leave their mountain fastness
but as the years passed the enmity
between our races waned
treaties were forged between the
remaining non-men and the norse arai
of tirsen salglich knowledge and goods
were exchanged and men learned for the
first time
of the incari and their wars against the
non-men
then under the heirs of uh ninkaru
telesur a non-man sorcerer
named uh katingara who you know is metic
rig from the sagas revealed the no
the location of minoricas to
the grand vizier of the ancient gnostic
school of
mangeka the glamour about the stronghold
was broken
and the schoolman of that school
reclaimed it to the woe of us
all so he goes on and he and he says
that
um you know eventually they they create
they became
enamored of their inhuman ways and they
fell upon their obscene and degenerate
craft the techne with the curiosity of
monkeys
most importantly they discovered the no
god
and so he goes on and he and he says you
know this is what you know from the
plains of all that
now here's the the key thing and coming
back to this theme
this is why i come to you now heed me
for i know of what i speak these
creatures these skin spies that
infiltrate your ranks
have no relation to the cicerom by
calling them such you simply do what all
men
do when assailed by the unknown you
dragging it into the circle of what you
know
you clothe new enemies in the trappings
of old
but these things hail from far outside
your circle
from time out of memory think of what we
saw moments ago these skin spies are
beyond your craft or ken
beyond even that of the siserum who you
fear and hate
they are agents of the consult and their
mere existence
oman's disaster only deep mastery of the
technique could bring such obscenities
to life
a mastery that promises the resurrection
of the no god is nigh
we mandate school men as you know dream
of the ancient world's end
and in all those dreams there's one we
suffer more than any other
the death of kelamas the high king of
kunari on the
right and he he then says listen you
this guy here in front of you he is the
prophet but he's also the result
of this prophecy and so if you want to
save the world save humanity you'd
better
figure out how to fix things and there's
there's one other
passage i want to bring up where we
actually get to see a good bit
about these um consults
right it's when the synthesis which is
one of the old names and the old names
are the people from the original consult
is talking with the skin spies
right and is engaging in some
discussion about who is who and what's
going on
and here here we go um what have you
learned
and this is the skin spy he's not cesaro
uh indeed the synthesis said then what
is he
dunyan and he's and then the synthet
says all games end with me
go worth all games sarkelis became very
silly i play no game
this man is dunya and that's what the
skill vendi calls him she said there's
no doubt
and then the the uh old name says but
there's no order called dunyan
in atrithau no but then we know he's not
a prince of there either the old name
paused as if to through as though to
cycle large human thoughts through a
small bird intellect
perhaps it's no coincidence this order
takes its name from ancient kunririk
perhaps this man's name is not a clumsy
sisrim lie after all perhaps he is of
the old seed
could the non-men have trained him
perhaps but we have spies even in
uh ish turibanth there's little that nin
kilgiris does that we don't know very
little no
it continued it continued this dunyan is
not a ward of the non-men when the light
of ancient
kunrir was stamped out many stubborn
embers survived
the mandate is such an ember perhaps the
dunyan is another
just as stubborn the blue eyes flickered
but perhaps
far more secretive and so what we have
here is
the the realization of
on the part of the consult the secret
enemy of who
their new enemy is uh the
dunyan and calhouse now notice that the
the
the uh consult are using the holy war to
try to destroy
the cicerone because it seems to them
that the system are the only ones who
can actually
resist them so lots of different things
going on in this lots of wheels within
wheels within
wheels one important theme that we
mentioned in the reviews of our scott
backers work as a whole and also fitting
into the
warrior profit is the status of
of women and i think that i would like
to focus primarily on
one main character because i think that
you can
make the charge that that stairway she
is developed as a character but
you know she's not going to go beyond
essentially being the
worshiper of kell huss and you know
part of this this uh community that
that's developing around it there's the
you know
relation between her and kanye and
calhouse that's going on
and there's the emperors as well
although i don't actually find her that
interesting of a of a character
myself nor do i actually find the
emperor particularly
interesting but estimate is
really an absolutely central character
throughout the entire prince of nothing
series going well
into the other four volumes of the
second apocalypse
and you know she's already been
developed as
quite a robust and interesting character
already
and i think you can say that one of the
threads that is
running throughout the warrior prophet
as well as back into the darkness that
came before and is going to run
into um the thousand-fold thought
is this love story between her and
akamian
where they you know they're they're
they're living this life where
he's a mandate sorcerer she is a
prostitute they can't
really be together but they are together
and you know you could say that their
their work life is
is precluding them from having the
fullness of a marriage
and then they you know they're apart
from each other
and there's this whole background of the
consult that that's going on as well
and then they find each other in the
course of the holy war
they're enjoying being together and
actually
like breaking some of the conventions
and the commitments
that they've made to others to enjoy
a full marriage and then catastrophe
hits right
then she you know she thinks that he's
dead
she winds up um becoming drawn
in by kell huss and there's a lot of
develop development that's taking place
on her part in this becoming a fuller
person becoming greater becoming
something
something new but then eventually she
also is
getting seduced by kell as as well
and then akamian comes back uh
victoriously
from his let's call it not even contest
but
you know small war with the scarlet
spires and so
estimate is a very interesting and like
i said well developed
character in this and i i i like the
idea that that um
backer expressed that he's not going to
try to shoehorn
characters you know through
representation into
uh things and there are some
um really important discussions that
happen
in in this work so one of them is when
she and akamian
come back together and she says um
you know you pretended i wasn't there
when they they encountered each other in
the previous book
what was she talking about akamian
pressed palms to his forehead wrestled
with the urge to lash out to punish
she stood close enough to touch after
all this time and yet she receded he
needed to understand
ask me what are you and she says what
was it akka
was i too polluted to defile too much a
filthy [ __ ]
no asked me i too bruised a peach i met
listen and she said so you're going to
take me to your tent you say add me to
the bushel
and he says you speak of bushels to me
and then he repents
and then he says i can explain
everything
s me and he says the night you're
talking about if i didn't see you
is because it wasn't because i was
ashamed of you how could i be
how could anyone let alone a sorcerer be
ashamed of a woman such as you
she bit her lip smiled through more
tears than why akamian rolled to his
side and laid next to her
his eyes searching the dark canvas above
because i found them as me that very
night
i found the consult right and
you know they talk together about all of
this
he and they have these conferences and
it's very
important that these are where they can
be like in full confidence with each
other and one of the things i do want to
say
that i think really comes through when
it comes to the character of essemet
we've already seen her characterized and
developed
as somebody who who learns
somebody who pays attention to things
somebody who wants to know about the
world
somebody who is exercising the intellect
and she's within a world
where women because of you know
patriarchy and misogyny and
all these assumptions that are going on
are being treated
as automatically inferior beings and
they live a
quite often a precarious existence
and there's a lot of interesting points
in here where the like the difference
between men and women
is is coming up here's here's a
an example where backer is actually
harnessing some john paul sartre
here we go according to that kamian
women had no instinct for principle for
them everything was embodied how would
he put it oh yes
that existence preceded essence for
women by nature the tracks traveled by
their souls ran parallel to those
demanded by principle the feminine soul
was more yielding more compassionate
more nurturing than the masculine
consequently principle became more
difficult
for them to see like a staff and a
thicket which is why women were more
likely to confuse
selfishness for propriety which
apparently was what
she was doing and and this is esimet
thinking about this thinking this over
so what we see here is a dialectical
transformation of what she's getting
from men
and then she's thinking through these
things and making it her own
i'd i'm this is going to sound rather
facetious but estimate is sort of like a
simone de bouvoir
or a hana arent in her own time working
within a world that's been
largely given to them by men
and you know thinking about things
through the
the realms of their own experience and
then
you know making something new of it
through
through this thinking um a little bit
later
in uh well actually a good bit later
in the work here we go
estimate talks about there being a
void in her learning and
here we go estimated tried many times
since her daughter's death to attend to
the void within her she tried
questioning away by asking the priest
she bettered but they always said the
same thing
that the god dwelt only in temples and
that she'd made a brothel of her body
then they would brothel her again
for a time she tried smearing it away by
coupling with men for anything half
coppers bread even a rotted onion but
men could never fill
only muddy so she turned to others like
her watching
observing she studied the always
laughing [ __ ] who somehow exalted and
being guttered
for day for night or the chirping slave
girls their faces anchored toward
forward beneath their water urn smiling
and rolling their eyes from side to side
she made their motions her emotions as
though certainty were a kind of dance
and for a time she discovered comfort as
though habits of gesture and expression
could drum
for a dead-end heart for a while for a
time she forgot the distance between a
fact and a face
she had never tried to love if joy and
gesture couldn't unseat desolation then
perhaps joy in
desperation right and she is in love
with with kamian but you know this is
again something where um
she is in the process of
ripening a becoming more that has been
going on
throughout her life she is really she is
a philosophical character
in a way that you know dwarfs
that of prayas maybe even knighter
um you know i would say calhouse akamian
that sort of trilogy of those three um
they're they're all calhouses of course
placed on a higher level in certain
respects but
the development that's going on the
realizations
she's actually sort of coming from
behind from being a woman
being illiterate having to like learn
everything
on the slide but in some respects she's
got a broader base
to draw upon
there's a a discussion that i wanted to
bring up as well about
women's places and roles
and here we go um
[Music]
so
yes here she's talking about um
you know waiting for a cameon when he's
gone missing
because the scarlet spires have taken
and she says
helplessness if women were hope's oldest
companions it was due to helplessness
certainly women often exercise dreadful
power over a single hearth but the world
between hearts belonging to men
and it was into this that akamian had
disappeared cold darkness between fire
pits
all she could do was wait what greater
anguish could there be than waiting
nothing etched the shape of one's
impotence with more galling meticulous
than the blank passage of time
moment after moment some dull with
disbelief others taught with voiceless
shrieks moment after
gnashing moment and she goes on a little
bit more
waiting this is what tradition said a
woman should do to wait at the hearth's
edge
to peer and peer and yet always be
stared down to haggle endlessly with
nothing
to think without hope of insight to
repeat words said and words implies
to chase hints into incantations as
though by their tumbling precision
and the sheer pitch of their pain the
movements of her souls might seize the
world at some deeper level
and force it to yield right and so
you know again she is making her own
as we say silent inquiries without
interior an interrogation without
hope of answer um
very important what she's going through
there and very important how it's being
depicted we're seeing it from uh within
her
own eyes and there's musing going on
i want to say a few other things about
her character and we could actually
spend an entire
session just unpacking these
when she does become involved with
calhouse
it's not as if she isn't already
learning before that
but she is able to
sort of you might say progress in in
higher
lessons calhouse is ultimately going to
teach her to read
and help her reinterpret you know
the religious texts that that ground
her identity in ways that she doesn't
want to you know
as somebody who's essentially condemned
by the tusk and by the other
the other religious writings
so she's going to have this already
formidable intellect that she's got
going on connected with
life a very practical but still
also you know metaphysical in the sense
of going into human nature and thinking
about society's
way of looking at things and it's going
to be unfolded and
unpacked and unfolded part of that is
happening through her relation
with kamian um but it's going to happen
even more
with kel huss in akamian's absence
and i think you can say that that's part
of
what produces the tension
between them so that's that's a
very important as well
i want to bring up one other passage
where she
ends up renouncing kamian
because i think it's it's quite
important
and this is where we also get to see
calhouse at work kel has turned once
more to essemet
peeled away her face with the hooks of
his gaze she'd already made two trips
from the fire to her tent promenades to
draw his attention and covertly gauge
his interest
she periodically looked from side to
side feigning amusement and things
elsewhere to see if he watched her
twice he let her catch him each time he
grinned with boyish good nature each
time she looked down blushing people's
dilated eyes blinking rapidly
her body radiating the musk of nascent
arousal though smet had not
yet come to his bed part of her ached
for him even wooed him and she knew it
not
for all her native gifts and this
is important she has native gifts and
she has developed them
she remained a world born woman as
opposed to being a dunyan right
and for all world-born men and women two
souls shared the same body
face and eyes the animal and the
intellect everyone was too
defective one estimate had already
renounced drusis akamian
the other would soon follow and
that renunciation is going to lead her
into
her greater involvement with calhouse
ultimately becoming
his consort in you know later
development of the story so
there's a lot going on here with this
this character
again we could explore this in much
greater detail but let's move on now to
talking about
this big character calhous
it's clear to me that this video is
going to go beyond the 90 minute mark
i'm going to try to keep things
relatively short and there probably are
a lot of philosophical themes that we're
not going to be able to get to
in even involving characters but the one
that we
absolutely cannot avoid i think is
what's going on with kalhus right so
who is the warrior prophet calhouse
right who is the prince of nothing
calhous and as we've seen in in you know
backer's on discussion of this
there there's a certain difficulty in
writing this this ultimately
seductive and self-moving
character so there's a couple
themes that i think we can bring up in
relation to
calhouse one of them is this idea about
being self-moved movers or not being
such right
the thoughts and and desires that that
produce our actions
produce our attitudes produce our words
coming from a darkness that goes before
and the goal of actually becoming
a self-move mover um
now that's that's something that the
dunyan are
centered upon and trying to teach and
that kel host brings into
the story he also notes that most people
do
think them of themselves as self-move
movers when perhaps they don't
really have a full right to to call
themselves
such and there's a couple things to
bring up with this one is that
as the warrior prophet as this develops
throughout the the work right and it
goes in stages
he is in effect taking over the movement
of the holy war both as a whole
and in its important moving parts like
you know
salban prayas uh even his
his opposition to confuse uh knight
is another important person involved in
this
as well and so he
is taking advantage of the fact that the
dunyan
through their understanding of
philosophy and human nature
are able to manipulate others are able
to understand
what what motivates them and
everybody else is essentially subject to
to being moved right
so there's some really interesting um
discussions here and i just want to
bring up um two of them
one happens in the course of these many
addresses that he is giving
as people are gathering around him as
the warrior prophet so this gives you an
idea of
what's what's happening so um
i'm going to read a little bit before
this the numbers attending
began to swell not so fast that akamian
could notice a difference between
consecutive nights but fast enough that
several dozen
had become hundreds by the time the holy
war neared
shigeck a handful of more devoted
listeners would assemble a small wooden
platform upon which they would lay a mat
between two iron braziers
calhouse would sit cross-legged poison
and immobile between the shining flames
usually he would wear a plain yellow
cassette looted from uh from the
sapitashas camp on the plains of mengeta
and somehow whether by posture bearing
or some trick of the light he would look
unearthly even glorious
so he's talking about what's happening
one particular
night and as always kel
searched the faces of those before him
his eyes glinting with compassion
after a few heartbeats his gaze settled
upon one man a quirinion knight by the
look of his tunic and the heft of his
gold rings
otherwise he looked haggard as though he
still slept on the battle plane
kelo says what happened and the nameless
knight says
you know we um we went to this village
hoping for plunder and what did you you
know kelvin says what did you find
a child a dead child we were following
this trail something worn by goat
herds i think cutting across this
hillside and there was just this dead
child a girl
no more than five or six lying in her
path her throat had been cut
what happened next nothing i mean we
simply ignored her continued riding
as though she were nothing more than
discarded cloth a scrap of leather in
the dust
he added his voice breaking he looked
down to his callous palms
guilt and shame wrack you by day calhoun
said that feeling that you've committed
some more mortal crime
nightmares rack you by night she speaks
to you the man's nod was almost comical
in its desperation he hadn't
acamian realized the nerve for war but
why he cried i mean how many dead have
we seen
and then kelos says but not all seeing
is witness
the man says i don't understand and
calhouse says
witness is the seeing that testifies
that judges so that it may be judged you
saw and you judged
a trespass had been committed and
innocent had been mar murdered
you saw this yes the man hissed a little
girl a little girl
and now you suffer but why he cried why
should i suffer she's not mine
she was heathen calhouse says
everywhere we're surrounded by the
blessed and the curse the sacred and the
profane but our hearts are like hands
they grow callous to the world and yet
our hands are like
or even the most cal like our hands even
the most callous heart
will blister if overworked or chafed by
something new
for some time we may feel the pinch but
we ignore it because we have so much
work to do
calhouse looked down into his right hand
suddenly bald it into a fist raise that
high
then with one strike with a hammer or a
sword and the blister breaks
and our heart is torn and then we suffer
for we feel the ache for the blessed
the sting of the curse we no longer see
we
witness and then the man says
what should i do and kelly says rejoice
rejoice but i suffer
yes rejoiced the calloused hand cannot
fear the
feel the lover's cheek when we witness
we testify and when we testify we make
ourselves responsible for what we see
and that that is what it means to belong
somebody says should we celebrate
suffering prince calhouse says
then it's no longer suffering is it no
that's not what i mean
celebrate the meaning of suffering
rejoice that you belong
not that you suffer remember what the
latter prophet teaches us glory comes in
joy and sorrow
joy and sorrow and then the man says
i see the wisdom of your words i truly
see but
and then calhouse says i'm not asking
you to see i'm asking you to
witness to be one with the world in
which you dwell to make a covenant of
your life and so this is a great example
of the sort of teaching
that calhouse is using and there's
something very true to it and yet we
know at the same time
that all of this is being done to snare
people in and at some points the guard
comes down
and you know knighter for example is
able to
reveal this about uh calhouse and about
the
donation i'm going to read a passage
regarding that that'll be a nice
opposite
to what we just looked at and so
here it is um
knier uh says that
you know he's he's realized what the
the dunian really are right and he
he finds that in a certain way
his life has you know
lost its sense and
it's its meaning right because of that
actually let me skip ahead to another
passage
that the passage i was thinking about
right there is where kaniah actually
asks
calhouse to kill him here we go um
a certain point um
i was looking at the wrong thing
he he says he knows the secret of the
the dunyan
right um
the dunyan make disciples of all men
whether they revere him or not
one need only breathe even my hate can i
or thought even my hate he uses to his
advantage
though his heart rankled at this it
rankled far more at the thought of
losing mengis
calhouse had spoken through those long
months pass in the uttamat camp
has heard it had only one quarry and it
could not be fed on surrogates
he was bound to the dunyan as the dunyan
was bound to stairways
corpse any shame any indignity he would
bear any injury commit any
atrocity to wet his vengeance he would
see the whole world burn before he would
surrender
his hate that was the obsessive heart of
his strength not his blade not his frame
his neck breaking wife striking shield
cracking
hate hatred had secured him the white
yash hatred had bonded his body with
holy scars
hatred had preserved him from the dunyan
when they crossed the steep
hatred and hatred alone had kept him
sane of course the dunyan had known this
after mengis canair had fled to the
codes of the people
thinking they could preserve his heart
and you know he goes on and he has a
sort of revelation
into things there are there were no
codes
there was no honor the world between men
was as trackless
as the step as the desert there were no
men
only beasts clawing craving mewling
brain gnawing at the world with their
hungers beaten like bears into dancing
to this absurd customer that all these
thousands these men of the tusks killed
and died in the name of delusion save
hunger nothing commanded the world
that was the secret of the dunyan that
was their monstrosity
that was their fascination
and so you know this is you know in a
certain sense
knight although akamian will have an
insight into this much later on
is the only one who can really see
what's going on with with
kel huss and the people that he
represents um
there's also a really interesting
discussion about fanaticism and betrayal
between akamian
and kalhus earlier on
in the work and remember akamian in this
work becomes
very quickly early on calhouse's teacher
first teaching him philosophy and all
this other stuff then later on
you know after debating at the gnosis so
he can become
a sorcerer himself but
very quickly it's apparent that this is
not an ordinary student he's just
soaking up
knowledge and akamian is being taught
himself in the process and not in the
way that we sometimes trivialize
and we we say oh you know the teacher
becomes the student
and i learned so much from teaching my
students more
again like this this pit opening up in
front of him
so um there's this discussion
that that goes on where um calhous
begins it by saying
there's more than one kind of fanaticism
the sorcerer's eyes widened momentarily
the narrowed and anxious thoughts of in
a row in the events of the previous year
an akamian said but not all fanaticisms
are equal
how do you mean not equal in principle
or not equal in consequence
the truth akambian said the truth
distinguishes them
no matter what the fanaticism in a three
consult or even mandate
the consequences are the same men die or
suffer the question
is one of what they die or suffer for
and calhous says
so purpose true purpose justifies
suffering even death
you must believe as such otherwise you
wouldn't be here
calhouse smiled as though abashed at
having been exposed so it all comes to
truth if one's purposes are true
akamian fills in anything can be
justified any torment
any murder then calhouse says any
betrayal
akamian steered his nimble face as stony
as you could manage
but calhouse saw past the dark skin past
the sheath of fine muscle
even past the soul that toiled beneath
he saw arcana
and anguish a yearning steeped in three
thousand years of wisdom
he saw a child beaten and bullied by a
drunken father
he saw a hundred generations of neuroni
fisherman
opinion between hunger and the cruel sea
he saw seswatha
and the madness of war without hope he
saw ancient ketiah tribesmen
surged down mountains stops slopes he
saw the animal rooting and running
reaching back
to time out of memory he didn't see what
came
after he saw what came before and
any betrayal the sorcerer repeated dully
he is close
and your cause kalos pressed the
prevention of the second apocalypse
it is true there can be no doubt so in
the name of that cause you can commit
any act any betrayal
akamian's eyes slackened in dread and
calhouse glimpse to worry to flee to
become a question
the schoolman had become accustomed to
the efficiency of their discourse
rarely had they ever wandered from
question a question as they did now
it's strange that kamian said the way
things spoken with assurance by one
can sound so outrageous when repeated by
another
it troubles calhouse said because it
shows conviction is as cheap as words
any man can believe unto death any man
can claim your claim
so then he says so you fear i'm no
different than any other fanatic
and there's a very interesting
reflection on what motivates people the
holy war
and these conflicts are motivated by a
certain kind of fanaticism
that kel huss himself can take advantage
of
there's also one of the other key things
that's happening with calhous here
this consolidation of roles you know the
warrior
prophet two different things here
he's also going to become a sorcerer
ultimately in you know he's going to
attain a much greater role and why so
that he can
reach his father and so he can also
as he's now figuring out deal with the
the consult um
there's a lot of other things going on
but i think
where i want to um
finish up here i'll mention two other
things you should pay attention to
in the work there's this you know there
are these these uh
passages where as we saw in the previous
book we get to see some of calhouse's
training
so there's the unmasking room and the
neural puncture that we see happening
there is the discussion about fighting
conflict trees movement those are
important
but i think we should talk about one of
the things that's going to
in addition to making him a prophet
bring him to the point where he can
actually become
something even greater which is a
sorcerer
and akamian plays a central role in this
right
akamian has to decide whether to teach
him the gnosis
so here's a good passage do i teach him
the gnosis
to his gut he balked at the notion the
mere thought of surrendering the gnosis
to someone outside his school
made him blanch he wasn't even sure he
could teach calhouse the gnosis even if
he desired
his knowledge of the gnosis was the one
thing he shared with saswatha
whose imprint owned every movement of
his slumbering soul
never never in the history of their
school had a sorcerer of rank betrayed
the gnosis
only the gnosis had allowed the mandate
to survive
only the gnosis had allowed them to
carry seth watha's war through the
millennia
lose it and they became no more than a
minor school his brothers
akami anu would fight themselves to
extinction to prevent that from
happening
they would hunt both of them without
relenting and they would kill them if
they could
they would not listen to reasons and the
name jerusalem
would become a curse in the dark halls
of
artresis but what was this other than
greater jealousy the second apocalypse
was imminent hadn't the time come to arm
all the three seas
hadn't suswatha bid them share their
arsenal before the shadow fell
he had and wouldn't this make here's
where we see seductive
logic or good practical reasoning akami
on the most faithful of all mandates
schoolmen
in his bones he knew calhouse had been
sent the peril was too great and the
promise too breathtaking
he'd watched as calhouse consumed a
lifetime of knowledge in the space of
months
he'd listened as calhouse voiced truths
of thought more subtle
than aegenkos truths of passion more
profound than segenus
he'd sat in the dust gaping as the man
extended the geometries
of muritetus beyond the limits of
comprehension he corrected
the ancient logic then drafted new
logics the way a child might scribble
spirals with a stick what would the
gnosis be
to such a man a plaything what would he
discover what power
would he wield but what if estimate were
right now notice
estimate plays a role here what if a
kamian were merely the test like
old evil shakola in the tractate
offering
injuries sajanas his thigh bone scepter
his army as harem everything saved his
crown to stop preaching
prophet and sorcerer the tusk called
such men
shaman the word lay like a ziggurat in
his thoughts
immovable shaman no this is madness
for two thousand years mandate schoolmen
had kept the gnosis safe
two thousand years who is he to forsake
such a
tradition and so this is you know a
really important central
turning point calhouse is going to
become
this this pivotal point but not a
pivotal point
in the sense of you know the the axis
that everyone else
simply revolves around there are human
relations connecting all of these
people together and what i want to close
on
is reminding us that
calhouse himself although he's you know
extremely gifted and the product of all
this
you know genetic lineage and training
and
you know absorbing all of these other
things along the way
is in the process of learning
himself he had several big adjustment
periods
where he had to come to realize that for
example sorcery is real
and that you know prophecy might also be
real as well so what we're going to see
in this
is the development of
kelvis as a as a human perhaps
as a superhuman but still rooted in the
human
the potentialities that humanity has to
offer
and yet being connected to all these
people around him
and we're given a double image we could
say
this is what i'll actually close on we
have the calhous
who seems to be even more human than
than the human in the sense of showing
affection
uh understanding empathy all these sorts
of things and also
steel resolve for the good and at the
same time as canair has recognized the
dunyan
serve nobody perhaps not even
notions of goodness they may be fighting
against the evil of the consult
but they're not trying to bring about a
utopia
or completely straighten people out even
calhouse when he's doing good for others
he's serving his own purposes
and so there's this tension here that's
not
fully explored at this point it will
become more evident in the next book yet
to come
as well as the books following those
so i'm just going to leave it at that
[Music]
you